the modern climate change discussion but
it's like we're sitting in a car arguing
about the radio station and what channel
we're listening to we're ignoring the
fact that the car's sitting on a railway
track and the train's coming we've got a
bigger problems is there a comment
coming 100 it depends on what the time
scale I think he's just saying we are in
this Cosmic Shooting Gallery it's only a
matter of time yeah if we burnt every
last ounce of fossil fuel the end result
of that is that we averted the next
Cosmic impact then karmic debt paid you
want nuclear winter like that's what it
is like it blocks out the Sun for for
hundreds of years everything on Earth
dies you know you can't breathe outside
like the half of the world is on fire
it's apocalyptic